[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma maman avait très envie que je fasse
des études de droit
et moi j'aime beaucoup ma maman donc je
l'ai écouté
et je me suis inscrit en fac de droit
sans trop de conviction
mais avec l'idée qu'elle allait être
fière de moi
donc je me retrouve en amphi à
l'université d'Orléans
donc on se le dise j'étais pas
particulièrement passionné par ses cours
du coup ce qui devait arriver arriva
j'obtiens pas ma licence
je suis encore très jeune mais
je suis persuadé d'une chose
je provient d'une famille où on manque
d'argent
donc quoi qu'il arrive je sais que je
dois réussir
du coup je pars sur Paris sans diplôme
je sais que ça va être difficile mais je
sais aussi que j'aurais plus
d'opportunités professionnelles qu'à
Orléans
bon après de nombreuses péripéties la
reprise d'une formation courte endroit
l'envoi de centaines de CV je finis par
décrocher un job en cabinet d'avocat
d'abord dans un petit cabinet en droit
des étrangers et puis je finis par
intégrer un grand cabinet en droit des
affaires
alors autant vous dire que là ma mère
elle est très contente
avec cabinet d'avocat c'est un
environnement prestigieux
je gagne bien ma vie
elle est super fière de raconter ça à la
famille au pays à ses copines
son fils a réussi
mais il y a un hic
cabinet d'avocat c'est un environnement
qui est un peu un peu austère alors
désolé pour nos amis en cabinet d'avocat
en tout cas moi j'ai du mal à y trouver
ma place pourtant ça a été compliqué
déjà d'arriver jusqu'ici donc bon je
lutte et en plus vous savez ce qu'on dit
des juniors ils sont trop instables ils
changent tout le temps de jobs donc je
me dis que coûte que coûte là il faut
que je fasse un effort je vais essayer
de rester je vais essayer de trouver un
équilibre du coup
c'est trouver un équilibre mais en vrai
j'accroche pas
je fais l'effort plusieurs années
passent ça va toujours pas
je suis tellement malheureux que je me
dis au final je me dis que peut-être
même peut-être pas si grave au final de
pas de pas kiffer son quotidien de pas
aimer son job
mais je suis tellement malheureux que
finit par tout quitter du jour au
lendemain
ce que je suis vraiment à bout
c'est une rencontre au réseau qui fait
que j'atterris dans le monde du
recrutement complètement par hasard sans
jamais avoir fait de formation dans le
recrutement sans jamais avoir imaginé
travailler là-dedans d'ailleurs ça m'a
valu un beau syndrome de l'imposteur bah
oui on est en France et en France bah
quand t'as pas la bonne expérience ça va
pas
et quand t'as pas non plus le bon
diplôme ça va pas
mais bon moi je mets tout ça de côté en
vrai j'adore l'environnement j'adore
l'écosystème
je sens que j'ai enfin trouvé ma place
quelques années plus tard je finis par
lancer mon agence enfin new way avec
deux missions aider les étudiants à
mieux s'insérer sur le marché de
l'emploi ah ouais je me souviens que moi
à l'époque personne était venu m'aider
et puis la deuxième mission aider les
entreprises à mieux recruter avec de la
marque employeur
je deviens créateur de contenu sous le
nom de Tonton Karim
très suivi sur les réseaux sociaux
et le top Voice par LinkedIn France
plusieurs fois bon
vous allez dire il est certain mais
pourquoi il me raconte sa vie comme ça
[Musique]
parce que ça a été compliqué pour moi de
trouver mon chemin
ce reste est compliqué parce que entre
les envies de carrière de ma mère les
miennes
mes passions
mes peurs
l'état du marché de l'emploi
ça n'a pas été simple et du coup
comment on fait
pour trouver son chemin comment on fait
pour trouver ce qui nous fait vraiment
vibrer comment on fait pour vraiment
trouver ce qui va nous permettre de nous
épanouir au quotidien
est-ce que c'est l'argent est-ce que
c'est le fait de d'avoir un job qui nous
passionne au quotidien
ça voudrait donc dire que si on fait pas
un job qui nous passionne c'est qu'on
n'est pas à sa place c'est compliqué en
vrai
on a d'ailleurs vu avec la crise du
covid qui a un soufflet du coup beaucoup
de changements dans l'état d'esprit des
gens on a notamment beaucoup parlé de la
quête de sens du coup
trouver un job trouver la bonne place
est-ce que c'est faire un
un job qui a du sens
c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué parce qu'en plus le
choix que tu vas faire il va te suivre
toute ta vie
quand tu rencontres quelqu'un
tu as une soirée ou tu as un date une
des premières questions qu'on pose c'est
tu fais quoi dans la vie
et tu réponds du coup par un métier tu
réponds par une formation tu peux pas
répondre rien
tu peux pas répondre rien parce que
aujourd'hui dans la société actuelle on
est défini par ce qu'on fait dans notre
métier moi j'aimerais qu'on se pose un
instant sur ce qui est le plus important
pour vous d'un point de vue
professionnel
donc je vais vous afficher une liste de
4 items que je vais vous inviter à
classer du plus important pour vous au
moins important
est-ce que le plus important est-ce que
c'est l'argent
est-ce que le plus important c'est
d'avoir un package intéressant une belle
revalorisation chaque année votre
salaire est-ce que le plus important
c'est le sens au travail avoir un projet
innovant responsable cultivant la
diversité la transparence
est-ce que le plus important c'est les
perspectives d'évolution ok envie de
continuer de vous former de monter en
compétences de gagner en responsabilité
ou enfin ce que le plus important c'est
les conditions de travail avoir le côté
flexibilité
l'équilibre pro perso avoir un bon
environnement de travail
je voulais juste quelques instants pour
adresser vu que votre liste affiche du
coup les quatre
ça va pour vous
on a choisi
est-ce que vous pourriez lever la main
s'il vous plaît tout ce qu'on choisit
l'argent en premier levez la main
l'argent vous inquiétez pas personne ne
vous voit donc
et comment qui vous verrez OK
est-ce que vous pourriez lever la main
ce qu'on choisit le sens au travail en
premier
ok plus de monde
est-ce que vous pourriez lever la main
ce qu'on choisit les perspectives
d'évolution en premier
c'est de regarder en même temps
et enfin ce que vous pourriez lever la
main c'est qu'on choisit les conditions
de travail en premier là il y a du monde
bon évidemment il y a pas de bon
classement il y a ton classement à toi à
l'instant T ce classement il va
évidemment évoluer avec le temps
moi quand j'ai démarré ma carrière je
voulais de l'argent mais ce que j'en
avais pas
honnêtement aujourd'hui c'est de la
chance je gagne très bien ma vie
et je pensais réellement que l'argent
allait tout changer
et ça a pas été le cas enfin pas comme
moi je l'avais imaginé je pensais que
l'argent me rendrait très heureux
au final
pour moi réussir sa vie c'était gagner
beaucoup être connu reconnu dans son
domaine
écrire un livre
faire un TEDx peut-être
il y a un an pourtant il y a un truc qui
a changé ma vie
j'ai acheté une maison pour ma maman
et ça pour le coup ça a tout changé
parfois la réussite elle est pas là où
vous vous attendez
trouver son chemin c'est pas toujours
facile
prenez le temps de vous perdre
l'essentiel c'est de vous trouver
merci à tous c'est carrément
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]